alessia
chirac s'est opposé à la guerre d'irak
il peut obtenir des américains que votre
fils ait un procès équitable
si vous l'aviez en face de vous jacques
chirac vous lui diriez quoi je veux lui
dire monsieur le président la vie de mon
fils il est entre vos mains et deux mois
le sauver s'ils méritent une
condamnation parce que hélas i mean et
avic si ce mouvement qui les malfaiteurs
s'ils méritent une condamnation faut le
faire mais pas une condamnation à mort
ni une condamnation à vie parce que pour
une mère c'est dur
s'il arrive ça mon fils aujourd'hui et
peut arriver à quelqu'un d'autre alors
c'est pas possible de laisser les
américains faire qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent avec les enfants des autres
merci un humain
et c'est richard ça va déjà mieux qu'il
ya une semaine
oui beaucoup mieux mais c'est déjà bien
oui oui petit à petit petit à petit et
oui je sais que cette courageuse mais à
notre combat parce qu'il faut il faut y
aller
les empêcher de condamnés à vie parce
que je vous dis pas quand je le lis je
les devants et en face de moi avec
kingdom en chine y est que j'embrasse la
vitre pour embrasser un enfant que j'ai
fait au monde et que je n'ai plus le
droit de le voir ni le torchis je le
souhaite à personne c'est qu'est ce que
je peux vous dire c'est très dur mais
j'ai fait devant lui je fis la forte
parce que je sais qu'il dit maman je
veux que tu sois forte je suis là je
viendrai j'ai rien fait confiance je lui
dis oui mais quand je sors de là crois
moi que je ne vois rien je vois rien je
sans rien vous êtes courageuse merci
m
il